this is a footnote to the main video on
Bayes theorem if your goal is simply to
understand why it's true from a
mathematical standpoint there's actually
a very quick way to see it based on
breaking down how the word and works in
probability let's say there are two
events a and B what's the probability
that both of them happen on the one hand
you could start by thinking of the
probability of a the proportion of all
possibilities where a is true then
multiply it by the proportion of those
events where B is also true which is
known as the probability of B given a
but it's strange for the formula to look
a symmetric in a and B presumably we
should also be able to think of it as
the proportion of cases where B is true
among all possibilities times the
proportion of those where a is also true
the probability of a given B these are
both the same and the fact that they're
both the same gives us a way to express
P of a given B in terms of P of B given
a or the other way around so when one of
these conditions is easier to put
numbers to than the other say when it's
easier to think about the probability of
seeing some evidence given a hypothesis
rather than the other way around
this simple identity becomes a useful
tool nevertheless even if this is
somehow a more pure or quick way to
understand the formula the reason I
chose to frame everything in terms of
updating beliefs with evidence in the
main video is to help with that third
level of understanding being able to
recognize win this formula among the
wide landscape of available tools in
math happens to be the right one to use
otherwise it's kind of easy to just look
at it not along and promptly forget and
you know while we're here it's worth
highlighting a common misconception that
the probability of a and B is P of a
times P of B for example if you hear
that one in four people die of heart
disease it's really tempting to think
that that means the probability that
both you and your brother die of heart
disease is one in four times one and
four or one in sixteen after all the
probability of two successive coin flips
yielding tails is 1/2 times 1/2 and the
probability of rolling 2
one's on a pair of dice is 1/6 times 1/6
right the issue is correlation if your
brother dies of heart disease and
considering certain genetic and
lifestyle links that are at play here
your chances of dying from a similar
condition are higher a formula like this
as tempting and clean as it looks is
just flat-out wrong
what's going on with cases like flipping
coins are rolling two dice is that each
event is independent of the last so the
probability of B given a is the same as
the probability of B what happens to a
does not affect B this is the definition
of independence keep in mind many
introductory probability examples are
given in very gamified contexts things
with dice and coins where genuine
independence holds but all those
examples can skew your intuitions the
irony is that some of the most
interesting applications of probability
presumably the whole motivation for the
kind of courses using these gamified
examples our only substantive win events
aren't independent Bayes theorem which
measures exactly how much one variable
depends on another is a perfect example
of this
[Music]